what the pollination is even my one word
is believe and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves and my
sincere hope is that if you see in you
what I see in you you'll be able to
change the planet I'm excited to launch
a new potential series this is the first
in the series called
ant roundup where the idea is so this is
the concept we take a clip from
different entrepreneur related channels
channels that I look up through channels
that inspire me some of the trails that
I'm paying attention to and take one of
their clips that I think is one of the
best style for the past month and give
you a snippet of it and mash them all
together as kind of the best of the
month so you're limited on time and you
don't want to watch everybody's channel
and everybody's video this is kind of a
sneak peek into the world of a couple of
awesome austrailia channels and
hopefully get inspired to make a change
in your business in in your life so I'm
looking forward to launching the series
and hearing your
[Music]
so this is strange for me I'll be real
anybody else
during watching the Olympics especially
track and field over the last like 20 30
years who dominated and track and field
who USA dominated you add Carl Lewis
Michael Johnson Michael Dokken came with
you go shoes off
I'm just tryin Ohain Tobias link in the
Gulf of the USA cursor was there they
was murdering them and all of a sudden
something happened and look ya'll think
I'm talking about him and I'm not I'm
not dealing with him I'm telling you the
environment you're in it's so important
not just God this guy is not only to
mother the field but what happened was
oh man he murdered the field he don't
compete he dominated but what he did for
Jamaica was not bringing a gold medal he
brought a culture to Jamaica he did
bring a championship home he brought a
kosher home gotta help y'all let me
explain them to you
so you an America and they're sending
you that is this distance is this is his
record so theoretically you know how
fast you come on you hear me
theoretically you know how fast is so
what you're doing when you practice it
is you try to be it sighs theoretically
I need you to hear what I'm saying this
is why you need to be in an environment
because theoretically they talk about
quickly needing to be and so you drink
and then you look at the clock and
coaches say you missed it all right try
again you try again and you missed it
but over in Jamaica it went racing
against a theoretical clock
they too became gold medallist and
dominated because they was running
against the real thing every single is
related to me what I said okay what run
against the clock they were in their
mind saying okay how fast did I go go
how fast I go they were rather get the
best men in the world so they knew I
better enjoy
[Music]
listen to me and the reason why you are
not where you want to be you want to be
a kid and you are running with sixes
every day you were hanging around five
every day the people you talk on the
phone to buy and if you became with it
they hate you so much that you're afraid
to be a kid because you're going to lose
them you a get around scrubs and when
you start with it all you do is win and
some of you are losers and all you need
to do is start hanging with some winners
and you're going to see when it and it's
going to spill over on just go to the
USC football team and I said something
in there that really caught my attention
I said something I'm sure you'll add it
and make it fly because that's how you
do it Dirac for 80 or 90 percent of you
this is going to be the best there's
gonna be as good as it gets this is the
prime this is the best and this rant is
about timing you need to be aware of
when you have your big opportunities you
squeeze so hard when you've got that
moment you have to understand that will
always change if it's terrible right now
it's going to get better if it is
phenomenal right now it is going to get
worse that is just the way it's always
been
I'm not smart it's just history so
please if you take anything out of this
mini little rant or d-roc it's about
timing recognize your moments and strike
that has absolutely been the foundation
of my success whether it was selling my
baseball cards when I just felt it
whether it was the Internet itself
whether it was other things like
starting vaynermedia when I had all
these other opportunities but I want to
triple down on my strengths during this
golden era sometimes they're fun
sometimes they're taking a step back in
theory but it's all about knowing when
to go all-in and the one thing we get is
regret when we didn't squeeze our best
opportunity so when you're a football
player at UFC that is a big time
opportunity because most of you don't go
to the league and most of you aren't
successful in the league and this is
your apex and whether you're a manager
in a store right now whether you're a
great student in high school whether
you're awfully pretty
now but you know you're not going to be
as pretty one day I'm being serious now
I know there's a silly
when you have your best situation when
you have the leverage you need to strike
and when you don't you don't pout you
put in the work to rebuild your next
leverage I had YouTube
I had Twitter and when they weren't as
big and more I didn't cried it Instagram
or snapchat came I put in the work to
build myself back up and matter in that
ecosystem and now that I've got the
Instagram moment again I'm pounding I'm
pounding harder than I did the last time
because I learned because when pattern
recognition from experience you get
better and so if this can inspire you if
you're good right now
quadruple down and if it's not stay
quiet and bills and look for that moment
when you know it's good
pound because squeezing when you have
the opportunity to instigate
that's a characteristic that I see in
almost everybody that I respect they all
think that everything they do sucks or
at least they have very very high
standards and an often disappointed by
their own work well you know I think I
have some of that but I also have that
idea of like it's something that my
thought I don't I talked about my dad
with you but um he was my wrestling
coach in high school he was also my
science biology and environmental
studies teacher really is my teacher I
was dragged went to school your dad's
being the t does the other me but I
learned a lot because he was no joke he
didn't pull any punches from it he you
know he drove me to hard if not harder
than his other students he didn't show
any favoritism but one of the things it
was always his thing on the mat and I'm
kind of paraphrasing but basically you
you either win or you learned mmm
especially in that high school college
setting you're you're learning about
yourself if you if you went out there
and you got your ass handed to you then
you just got beat and didn't learn
anything yeah your loser you take the
moment reflect on it build on what you
did wrong and you now you're actually in
a way you've won now you know more about
yourself you know but more your your
limitations or what you need to improve
and expand your talents or your
limitations so I guess whenever I'm
doing a thing
I'm always looking at it from a learning
perspective so there aren't necessarily
mistakes unless they're fatal and then
you didn't know anyway so whatever that
really is the right way to look at
everything you win or you learn yeah you
know you have great experiences because
you're successful or you have very
beneficial experiences because you
realized what went wrong yeah but you
just one more wrinkle one more piece of
information or one more experience that
you can add to your database of
knowledge and it will make you better
everything video
how do you cope working in an
environment where there is so much
malicious people and envy where only the
powerful ones get a break and the
introverted are left out
how do you cope working in that
environment hmm well I'm not introverted
so I don't have a problem with that but
I think in an environment where the
delicious people and envied malicious
people in Envy I just try to stay in my
lane and focus as much as I can on my
vision now sometimes I get off-track and
I allow negative negative conversations
or comments to affect me and I'll talk
about them I'll think about them for a
couple of days but typically I'm pretty
good at being committed to my vision
staying in my lane you know my friend
chalene johnson show I said run dirt run
your own race I'll try to run anyone
else's race don't try to be like anyone
else or you have to keep up with other
people and so I really just focus on
my vision and you know being committed
to that so that's what I try to focus on
I remember early on I got in a in Co
2009 I got in a Twitter battle with this
guy that I never met
he was another like marketing social
media guy that he might have written a
book or something he had a little bit of
credibility in the social media space
and I remember he said something that
offended me and I started tweeting back
and she kind of fed into my you know
going back and forth and we were like
for three days just like both reacting
to each other calling each other names
and I remember some people were like
supportive and like jumping on on with
me and like kind of going after him and
then at one point in day two someone was
like you just need to let this go this
is not look one that doesn't look good
for you to it's a waste of your time and
three it's taking away from your vision
and I remember early on just that less
than I can remember can told me that but
I remember early on just being like hmm
yeah this is not helpful just to
constantly combat with other people who
are malicious or envious or attacking in
any way so anytime I see negative
comments now or anything that I feel
like could take me off track I just
smile or say thanks for the feedback and
keep keep focused and I think that's
what you should be focused on is
staying committed to the vision and on
running your own race how do you stay
motivated and how do you motivate people
when they start to slack now motivation
is its kind of a strange word because it
doesn't really mean what we think it
means we think it means that we're fired
up to do something we think that it
means we're eager and passionate to make
something happen and we think that
somehow we should just be able to turn
on that eagerness and turn on that
passion but we can't cuz you just can't
turn on passion you can't just turn on
the desire to execute a task just
doesn't work that way and honestly that
isn't even what motivate means motivate
doesn't mean to yell and scream and
encourage no to motivate actually means
to provide a motive a reason why so to
motivate someone is to explain to them
why they're doing what they're doing how
it will help them where it'll take them
why they should continue to work in the
struggle and to fight and when you need
motivation yourself or work for someone
to scream and yell don't look for
someone else to give you motivation
yourself look at yourself and remind
yourself why why you are doing what you
are doing remind yourself that this
struggle this temporary pain this fight
this fight that you're in this is what
will make you stronger and faster and
smarter and better and then with that
motivation go forward into the fray into
the storm into the heat of the battle
where victory is forged
you have boundless energy and intense
white-hot Drive and dream so big they
wake you up and sweat every night but if
you don't dominate all the air is your
life you will collapse under the many
forms constructive forces take you must
be the leader in all areas if you can
dominate your own thinking you your
employees thinking your competitors
thinking and the public's thinking then
you own the space but it starts with you
it's a bad idea to ignore your ambitions
it's a worse idea to deny your energy
and your obsessions but it's even worse
to let them take their own course
confidence is vital not only to staying
on this course but also to setting the
course reinforcing that course for
everyone and then making sure you win
the best way to gain confidence is to
dominate your space if you know you're
weak in a certain area or move to
dominate the problems so that it is no
longer an issue there is no domination
without discipline this place was built
on people not having the energy and the
creativity to say I want to create my
own game in life money is a major area
that you absolutely have to dominate but
most people money is a constant concern
but most of us have been taught that
money is the root of all evil I mean
some of the stuff that we've been
talking about money is just ludicrous
what does that even mean the root of all
evil
look it's not true that it takes money
to make money it's just another lie the
truth is it takes courage to make money
but there's so much money on this planet
it is mind boggling that so many people
think about so little all the time most
people don't have any money because they
believe there is a shortage of money and
they believe they don't deserve money
and that it's hard to get money see I
take the attitude that money is
everywhere I see it everywhere I go look
if you don't like people you're not
going to have money because people have
done
you want everyone has money hey I wish
for you
you can make positive changes to
dominate every sector of your life
starting right now you can combine feed
and strengthen multiple areas at want as
long as you are obsessed with your life
and not a sector Bill Gates says if you
were born poor if not your fault if you
stay poor shame on you
my intention in creating master class
came from the understanding that
everybody's story is the same all
stories are connected and there is
nothing that anyone who's living on
earth has ever felt unknown or
experienced on a soul level that hasn't
been felt or known or experienced by
someone else one of the most difficult
things in life is feeling that you are
the only one you are the only one who's
travelled this path and felt this way I
had nowhere to go I was homeless at the
time I lost my family next thing I know
I'm in this car for three years but I'm
struggling who's experienced such
devastation or joy or triumph or victory
so for me I define a master as someone
who has fully stepped in and owned the
full progress and trajectory of their
life the census pays off that's lesson
one but hearing stories told from the
mouths of people who know how to live
how to course-correct
how to keep going how to never quit how
to rejoice in the good times and have
faith in the bagged
those people are masters anyone who can
do that is a master and their ability to
share their stories only helps the
trajectory of others listen
[Music]
so the Instagram live folks if you
couldn't hear this he was asking about
concert photography how do I get started
how do I have a relationship with these
folks start small but start like all
this pontificating wondering like you
have a camera are you going to a show or
you I don't care if you're buying a
ticket a $9 $10 ticket to go to the
local show you start taking pictures
because the area that you're talking
about working in is very specialized
it's hard to break into it's hard to
make real money and I'm just setting
these things up for you like this is the
reality of the situation that you're
asking me to do I don't know if you want
to make a living in a life tuned to
stuff or if this is the hobby but it's
very hard to break into and it's very
hard to make money I want that to cue
one or two things in you you either go
well I don't give a [ __ ] like I'm this
is the thing I'm doing I want to do this
more than anything and I'm going to do
what it takes and if it's hard that's
awesome because there'd be less
competition thing too would be like oh
my god chase says it's hard to make
money and break in I don't want to do
that if Chase is where is really hard
great then don't do something go do
something else because you didn't really
want it bad enough let's pretend you're
in the first camp you want you're like I
don't care I'm going to do this this is
my calling in life if that's the case
start small start taking pictures by the
$10 ticket work your ass to the front of
the row the thing you can smash in
you're taking those photographs what can
you do to a get greater your craft B go
there all the time not just on the
Friday and Saturday shows shoot all of
the shows because you got to put in time
to master your craft if you're just
another sort of low to medium level
concert photographer
no money no game it's not going to
happen for you might be fun and you
might be able to get a couple free shows
out of the deal but I'm not assuming
that that's your goal I'm assuming that
you want to be the best and I could be
wrong so take this with a grain of salt
but if you want to be the best you have
to how are you then so known that the
first club they start you know the
owners you know the sound guys you know
the bands that are coming how into it
are you are you doing the other 50% this
freaking thing comes up in every single
ever
so the video that I put out called the
other 50% you should watch that are you
doing the other 50% then it go beyond
that one club are you the guy who's
known like oh man I I got I got the
Pixies are coming I want a savior to
shoot it you have to become that guy and
the way you do it is you're there all
the time
this just showing up you've heard that
just showing up is half the game you
have to have talent you have to be
skilled you have to have all those
things but just being so relentless with
your pursuit of the thing is incredible
I am The King I was you any man who must
say I am the king is no true king this
is the most important sentence that
Tywin ever says according to Tywin power
does not come from telling other people
that you have it it comes from showing
them Tywin does that in many ways and I
want to start with some of the sub
communications of power meaning the
things that Tywin does with his body
language and his voice and I have to
give Charles dance here massive amounts
of credit because he did a phenomenal
job of acting these things out so let's
explore how Tywin enters crowded
conversations first off with a boom I'm
told we still have his sisters the first
order of business is ransoming so Jamie
no truces we can't afford to look weak
we should march on a mad one first we
must return to Casterly Rock to rape huh
my son now you may struggle to be heard
when there's a lot of people speaking
many of us do you might stop and start
try to find your way in politely and
ultimately not get listened to at all
but not Tywin he startles people by
going from silent to booming in an
instant that grabs attention immediately
but what's interesting is that he often
doesn't stay booming for too long once
he has attention he quiets right back
down this makes his quiet mode of
interaction just as frightening as his
booming tone because you never know when
he's going to switch hey hi son get up
all of you
you don't need to scream like Tywin does
but the lesson of entering with a
slightly louder and deeper tone is one
that applies just as well to modern day
interactions pay attention to any group
and you'll see that the person who is
listened to when there's a lot of people
trying to speak is often the loudest
when entering don't stay loud forever
though if you're going to use this small
piece of advice because that can just be
obnoxious you may also have noticed that
Tywin is very comfortable with silence
this is a Power Move that I discussed in
another video so I won't spend too long
on it and I'll link to it here if you
want to click the little white button in
the corner but Tywin likes to use
silence right after people have said
something to provoke him it gives them a
few extra seconds to regret their
decision to stand up to him and to sit
in fear of what he
I do next my father won the real war he
killed Prince Rhaegar he took the crown
while you hid on a costly Rock
[Music]
the king is tired see him to his
chambers the silence that Tywin makes
create to stare down like you might see
for boxing or UFC promotions the first
person to flinch or look away loses
which is why fighters go to such great
lengths to not give an inch of ground
and this isn't just an arbitrary rule
that was made up for boxing flinching
and breaking eye contact are built in
evolutionary tells that communicate fear
which is why they can sometimes matter
even more than raw strength when it
comes to a confrontation because when
one animal isn't afraid that's a good
sign that it has an advantage that needs
to be respected just watch this charging
gorilla back off when a puny little
human doesn't flinch even though the
gorilla could obviously tear him limb
from limb charged and charged and
charged again and I think and I'm sure I
would have even finished one but Tywin
sub communications of power go beyond
the a prompt his word choice is a
distinctly human way of using power he
doesn't ask people what to do or make
threats by saying if you do this and I'm
going to respond like this he tells
people what they are going to do using
the word will it conveys absolute
certainty that they will do as they are
told and again the certainty that Tywin
will be listened to adds to the sense
that he should be listened to
taking action is a cure-all taking
action solve all the problems that
you're going through whatever problem
you have whatever thing is in front of
you whatever obstacle is there that
seems insurmountable
it's not going to get fixed by just
sitting and complaining and wallowing
and feeling sorry for yourself
it happens so I'm taking action as soon
as you can move from that place of being
unhappy and desperate and sorry for
yourself to how do I solve this who do I
need to contact the help me how can I
use the resources I have to fix this as
soon as you start moving to that land
that's when you start to make progress
taking action is the cure-all and this
will happen so many times the
entrepreneurs not even just with
problems but with ideas in general how
often you get an idea for something that
you want to do and then you say tomorrow
I'm going to do it and then tomorrow
come to you don't do it how many does
that happens that happens over and over
and over and over and against the human
condition such as entrepreneurs we have
these things these ambitions these
drives that we set for ourselves and
then we don't follow through on the best
way to start on that idea you have is to
take action do something immediately as
soon as you set a goal I want to start a
YouTube channel
great what are you gonna do on your
YouTube channel I want to interview
people amazing today set up your YouTube
channel and send out ten emails to
people to ask them for interviews people
that you know people who you think will
say yes when you commit to somebody else
you're much more likely to follow
through and what happens is perfection
because the enemy of action you want to
make it perfect and because you make it
perfect it gets more and more and more
and more and more complex and complexion
is the enemy of execution because you
build up to this big thing this big
scary thing asked me perfect you don't
do anything before I setup my youtube
channel I need to have the perfect
channel art I need to have the right
some nails and I need to know what my
script is going to be and I need to know
my into an opener or anything here and
all of these things that you need to
have to make a perfect video because it
becomes a big thing you don't do
anything about it and then the next day
you wake up and it's got poop
as soon as you set a goal for yourself I
want to go and do this the best next
thing you can do is take some form of
immediate action and ideally commit to
somebody else whether it's a friend
whether it's a potential customer
whether you're sending emails out
whether it's your family whether it's a
neighbor commit to somebody else because
when you do that you're much more likely
to follow through because you won't let
them down
you'll let yourself down all the time
you let yourself down every morning when
you wake up and hit the snooze button
you let yourself down the first thing
you do in the morning is let yourself
down we've got a goal boom I let myself
down you let yourself down all the time
but you won't let other people down
nearly as much so taking immediate
action and then follow through with
somebody else so that you don't let
yourself and them down so thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
I'd love to know what did you think of
this video was there a lesson that
really run chill for you that you're
going to apply immediately somehow to
your business or your life leave that in
the comments really excited to see what
you have to say also should this series
continue this is a test series the first
edition there might be a volume - there
might be volume three or we might just
kill it altogether based on the result
what you guys have to say so let me know
if you have suggestions leave it down
below as well thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love cc